Let's go next. Where do we
want to go next? How about.
Oh, I don't know.
There's a lot of interesting callers here.
Let's go to, um, why don't we go to John from
Philly, John from Philly. You're on the air.
Hey, baby. How are you, sir? Good.
How are you? Very good, very good.
And I just discovered this
link to call you because I tried to call
you from the previous way to call you
from the six one seven, but is no longer work.
It's done. That's right. It's all discord now.
OK, so I was just wondering, what did
you believe the Republican Party is is
going to be like? I don't know. I feel like
the Republican parties don't play dumb.
John, did you say Dunn or dumb down completely?
Completely. Dunn OK. I don't believe they
can win, you know, the election in the
White House. I mean, I could be wrong.
I don't know anybody who will listen. So I
have two thoughts. John, we've spoken before,
right? You're from the Dominican
Republic, if I recall correctly. OK,
yes. Yeah, I remember you. So here's the thought.
On the one hand, when you look at what's going on
and you see how Donald Trump led to Republicans
losing the House in twenty eighteen, losing
the White House and the Senate in 2020, and
distrust in so many different aspects of what the
Republican Party stands for. It's hard to imagine
how could they win without changing what they're
doing. But we've said this many times before,
John, where we say, wow, the Republicans now, they
definitely can never win again and then they win
again. So I would be careful about saying there's
no way they can win. The things I'm going to be
looking out for are what happens in 2020 to do
Republicans in 2020 to reject the Trump in
candidates like Marjorie Taylor Green and others,
or do they get reelected? If they get reelected
in 2022, there will be a fight for who represents
the Republican Party in 2024. If in 2022, all
of these Trump people get voted out and the
Republican Party goes back to being what it was,
I think they'll probably be mostly back together
by the time of the next presidential
election. That's my thought right now.
So did you think they are not going to go back
to the values or being laid before they when
the Reagan turned on things like,
yeah, when he was in power, like the
whimsicality, the like the the focus on welfare
reform, trickle down economics, the dad religion,
that type of thing, you mean. Yeah. Like a priest
principle of being a conservative, right. Yeah.
That was the way or policy.
Well, now everything changed and now is
they are completely and all their
life far, far right now, right?
Absolutely, absolutely.
The Republican Party I'm not plan to be like a
party of hope of all races in power.
Well, the way
the way I would say it is they've become about
just angering the left. That's that's their
philosophy. Now, what can we do that will anger
the left? Trump was never about policy. The few
policies he ran on, like replacing Obamacare,
building a wall, fixing trade. He didn't do any
of those things. And for the last two years of
Trump, they didn't even pretend to care about
policy. So you're asking a great question, which
is do they go back to what they pretended to be
during the 80s and 90s? I think it's too soon to
know. I think we just have to wait and see, John.
Yeah, well, I don't know, to leave the Republican
Party is not going to be this thing anymore.
I think it'll never it won't even if it
goes back to being about what it was,
it will never be the same because they
can't erase the fact that they had Trump
for four years. And I think that's that will
cause some irreversible change for sure.
Yeah, yeah, I completely agree. Well, thank
you so much. Thank you, John. Appreciate it.
Hope the hope things are well in Philly. There's
John from Philly. Always great to talk to him.